- one boom and we're live first of all
cheers gentlemen let's have a little
toast relax Bob thank you very much for
doing this I really appreciate it I
understand that you've told this story
many many times you've been grilled many
many times and it's very stressful for
you so I really really appreciate your
time for people who don't know the story
there is a documentary
Jeremy Korbel it has a documentary out
right now it's called bob lazar area 51
in UFOs and flying saucers and flying
saucers air 51 in flight sometimes I
first heard your story decades ago I've
told you last night we went out to
dinner I've seen pretty much every
interview you've ever given I've
followed the story incredibly closely
but for people who don't know story
let's give them the bullet points you
used to work at area 51 and area 51
you got you you went like huh well you
know we want to be accurate Oh Kerry S 4
s 4 oh just about 15 miles south of area
51 okay um you worked in what would you
how would you describe it I guess
within the area 51 compound you can call
that a subset of area 51 and you got
that job before that you were working
before that I had worked at Los Alamos
right National Labs in New Mexico and
you were involved in what kind of work
the nuclear weapon development physics I
mean that's they do everything there so
how did they approach you to say hey
bomb
once you come on out to the Nevada
desert well the way this went down was
at that time I was 1982 I I put a jet
engine in my my Honda and Los Alamos put
it on the front page of the paper
said you know Los Alamos man physicist
at the lab you know built this 200 mile
an hour you know on the jet car that I
drove to work every day so
I was known in Los Alamos that the guy
with the weird car and you know you
could hear it from you know a mile away
anyway the day that came out on the
front page of the paper was the day
Edward Teller the father of the hydrogen
bomb was giving a lecture down there at
the lab and we didn't have much going on
that day in our group and I asked if I
could go down there and I went down
there early and Ed teller was outside
leaning on a brick wall there and
reading the front page of the paper now
there's a guy out of history so I
introduced myself hey I'm the guy you're
reading about there and we talked for a
little while and it was cool you know
fast forward two years later I had moved
out to Las Vegas and had you know left
Los Alamos and you know went on to other
things and I wanted to get back into the
scientific humanity yeah I left start
other businesses and and that sort of
thing so I sent resumes out and one of
them went out to Ed teller and
referenced our meeting you know back it
back in that the day and anyway he
remembered me and gave me a reference
somebody to contact at EG&G
and that's pretty much how it started so
you get a phone call or a letter like
what do you get well I got a what did I
get I got a letter initially and went
down for an interview probably a couple
times and it was down at EG&G special
projects which was at McCarran Airport
at that time out in Las Vegas and did
they give you any sort of job
description of what you were applying
for they said it was for Edie I can't
remember exactly what they did this was
a long time ago but I I think it was
advanced propulsion or something like
that something relatively generic and
they said it's in a remote area you know
it's gonna be some days on some days off
and you know it was kind of a it was
kind of not exactly a full-time job but
you might have to be out there for two
weeks at a time and take two weeks off
so
kind of uh the work schedule would be
kind of broken up and did this seem
attractive you or did it seem weird no I
really wasn't weird because people that
work at the test site anybody that's
familiar with the area up there you know
working at the nuclear test site or at
the Tonopah test range north of there
that's typically how things go so you
had known about it from the scientific
community because the area 51 at that
time know anything about area 51 okay so
they just said it was in a you know in a
remote location and you just know it was
up at the test site right so but there
was no mention of area 51 at that time
so they've done hundreds of nuclear
tests in Nevada Nevada that that whole
area was there's been just giant chunks
of Nevada the people yeah there's a big
piece of Nevada and it split up into
different areas there's a nuclear test
site
there's area 51 there's the Tonopah test
range north of that there's little sub
areas there's areas where they test
chemical weapons and things like that so
it's all broken up as a you know
gigantic test area so take me back to
first day on the job you accept a job
they take you out there yeah it's the
first day really I didn't really get to
see a whole lot the first day was
essentially just paperwork that's when I
flew into area 51 proper and I left
McCarran Airport and flu what they call
the Janet flights just you know a
passenger plane from Las Vegas to area
51 and it was really just going through
a mountain of paperwork that day from
security clearances to cat there was it
was like two or three hours of just
solid paperwork and that was that was
really an uneventful first day when did
things get weird when did you realize
they at what point in time did you say
hey this is not normal work like this
doesn't even seem like it's from this
planet that I can't tell you what day
that occurred on because so much time
has gone by the days of kind of fusion
to
and I can't listen today's was it a slow
burn or was there a moment of
recognition well they're the the first
inkling I had was when I I came in
normal there's this facility that is at
s4 it's in the side of a mountain and
normally we had pulled in with the bus
and gone around the front through a
normal double door this time that I went
in there were hanger doors open I went
into the hangar door and in the hangar
door was the disk the flying saucer
that I worked on I saw it sitting there
and we walked by a headed little
American flag stuck on the side and I
thought oh my god this finally explains
all the flying saucer stories this is
just an advanced fighter and it this is
[ __ ] hilarious
so I went by I sloughs my hands
alongside it I got reprimanded
immediately for touching the thing and
there was a guy in armed guard that
followed us in and just said keep your
eyes at forward in your hands at your
side and just walk in the door so that
was the first time I had seen anything
that was weird it was sometime later
that I was introduced to my my lab
partner Barry and we had some of the
subcomponents of the craft in the lab
and Barry was very anxious to get a new
lab partner so he was very talkative and
couldn't wait to show me different
things and it was in the demonstration
of the reactor working where it caught
my attention to where this is technology
that doesn't even exist so I mean that
was the first time I knew that this is
really something different what was it
what was it what was a what was it about
this reactor that made you think that it
didn't exist
technologically well it was that I
actually have to back up because there
were some briefings that I read it
before that that you know certainly gave
me the impression that this was going to
be a weird job but this was the first
hands-on thing this was a small reactor
about the size of a hemisphere about the
size of a basketball on a metal plate
and when it was running it produced a
gravitational field a gravitational
field of its own now this is something
that we can't do we can't produce any
gravity the only way we get gravity is
from large quantities of mass but
there's no machine we can have that
turns on that makes gravity like you
know you can turn on an electromagnet
and it makes a magnetic field we can't
make a gravitational field
anyway this device was producing that
and Barry said it's almost like he was
bragging go ahead try and try and touch
the sphere and I I couldn't it would it
pushed my hands away just like two like
poles of a magnet so that was like when
you take two magnets and try to press
them together yeah yeah kind of cushion
feeling but you can't you can't get them
together the closer you put them the
more they push but you felt that
physical with my hand yeah now there's
nothing there's nothing that does that
and that immediately caught my attention
going wow this is something else what
was your thought like when you felt that
and you knew that there was nothing that
you were aware of that could predict
that connected me to the briefings that
I read on the the first day at s4 was
that you know everything that I had read
was apparently accurate what were you
reading I read it was kind of an
overview this project was to back
engineer the alien craft and
specifically it was to try and back
engineer and see if we can duplicate the
technology with available materials now
to do this they split the project into
you know many different pieces for
several reasons they do this on all
classified project so nobody has the
complete story but they compartmentalize
everything now we had the power and
propulsion system
so what briefings they gave me were like
a one or two page overview of some of
the other projects that were going on
you know on the craft the only reason
they do that is just in case what you're
working on is connected intimately in
some way that we don't know of - one of
the other projects you have to know
there excuse me their existence so you
know I bet again everything from
metallurgy
- you know weapon potential the craft
and these were all you know essentially
very short briefings but mine was just
power and propulsion and it made it very
clear that what I read was accurate so
when you're reading that before you
actually saw the reactor what were your
thoughts on what they were describing if
you knew that something like that didn't
exist and they're describing it in the
briefings what did you think you were
gonna see I really I didn't know at the
time I mean I was reading I thought is
this is some kind of test see if you're
crazy well not to see if I'm crazy - you
know a lot of times they'll take in real
high security jobs I mean they'll
intentionally insert nonsense into him
whether it's to confuse the fact or if
for someone was to leak it out they
would carry that information along and
know where it came from so I read
through the documents but you know I
didn't know if this was you know part of
some kind of test or you know or what or
was it potentially realistic I mean I'd
really didn't consider it being all that
possible as far as being the actual
thing that I was going to work on at the
time how did they turn it on there the
reactor yeah the reactor can be turned
on or turned off in a lot of different
ways the way Barry showed me it the
hemisphere is removed there's a small
tower in the middle when you put the
hemisphere on the reactor activates the
reactor shuts down its its load sensing
so if there's if there's no load on the
reactor at all it shuts down when
there's a load present on it it starts
up again load meaning you can consider
it an electrical load so although it
doesn't necessarily operate electrically
there's no wiring that connects any of
the sub components together whatsoever
they just have to be in the immediate
vicinity it's a it is but the stuff is
borderline magic and that's essentially
where we left it
you know when I left the project so
there was no progress made there was
some progress I mean we did identify at
least we think some processes and and
had a rough idea we think of what was
going on but I think this is a problem
that they've had for a long time and you
know I was replacing somebody that Barry
worked with prior to me and I think
there was some horrific accident that I
didn't have a whole lot of information
on but you know Barry alluded to that a
horrific accident like where someone
died or yeah where somebody died because
they were trying to tamper with things
or figure out how something worked yeah
the reactor in particular but yet he let
you touch it yeah I think what they were
trying to do was cut into one now they
had they had more than one there and I
that was supposedly there was an
unannounced nuclear test and that's what
it was at the time remember they would
still do an underground nuclear test at
the test site but from what I understand
according to Barry there was an attempt
made now this must have been a pretty
desperate attempt because it's not a
very scientific process to cut you know
analyze something that way but it looked
like they used a plasma cutter or
something I got to cut into an exactor
how many of these things they have they
had nine nine craft altogether I only
got hands-on with one of them so I can't
really say what the how the others
operated you see the other ones yeah at
one time and only one time the bay doors
that between the hangars were all open
and I could see all the way through and
were they all exactly the same no they
were all different different shapes yeah
but they were all from somewhere else
yeah absolutely now did anyone make any
attempt to explain or to to tell you
where they came from no no no one is the
least bit interested in letting
everybody know all the facts they want
to give you the minimum information
that's necessary to complete your task
so you're not getting the story of where
they came from you're not getting the
story of what how much progress other
people are making you just focus on
the small component but they gave you
some indication that they've been
working on these for a while yeah when
do you think they acquired these I
really couldn't say I think they've been
around for a while so they bring you
into this room you see this reactor
working you you realize this is nothing
that as far as like the scientific
community at current time has the
ability to create wait you still don't
what is your life like from that moment
on is that where everything changes
because you do I mean I would imagine
the moment you actually make contact
with something that's extraterrestrial
whether it's an object or a being
something where you can actually
absolutely be certain it's not from here
your whole paradigm the whole world you
live in is now a different place well
this is the only time it became exciting
you know the rest of the time though it
was really an an ominous feeling being
at work but it at that time it was
exciting I mean this was now I knew we
were on the absolute beyond actually
beyond the cutting edge of science and I
was I was so absolutely excited to be
there every single time I was you know
it with this was a fantastic opportunity
and however in in short order it began
to concern me we really have no idea
what we're talking about and the
excitement kind of turned to dread at
some point because the amount of power
we're dealing with is astronomical
I mean to affect gravity to produce the
effects like this equipment does takes
huge amounts of power and I've given the
example before of you know taking a
small portable nuclear reactor and you
know putting it back into Victorian
times you know with the scientists at
the time and just dropping it in a room
and they come and look at it and see
that it's producing power and wonder how
it works so they start taking it apart
and as soon as they get some of the
shielding off the people are going to
drop dead because of the radiation
inside now the people have no idea that
it radiation even exists back then but
anybody that comes in to check on them
will also drop dead and you know there's
no reason that that exact scenario
couldn't happen with what we're dealing
with we have no idea
how the physics operate within this
thing the power levels are art like I
said astronomic like it's incredibly
dangerous to tinker with something like
that and you know in some respects we
were guinea pigs just try to find out
how to make this thing so they had a
series as far as you surmised that a
series of different scientists try to
back engineer this thing try to figure
out what this thing was and they would
bring in new people and like let's throw
Bob at it yeah yeah and they I know I
don't know how many but I knew there was
certainly one before me and I knew he
died during the analysis of the or the
reactor itself and you don't know how
many have worked on it and no one gave
this could have been there for 50 years
it could have been there for five years
when they give you instructions
what are they saying like when they're
giving you direction they're showing you
all this stuff like what what what are
they saying well specifically what are
they asking of you well essentially what
they ask is is what I said we are just
to gather as much information as
possible find out how it operates and
see if we can duplicate it so but they
notice relays you where it was from they
never let you ask questions about where
it's from well if the information I read
in the briefings was accurate now what I
do have to say is the information that
pertained directly to the reactor was
accurate what I read did I mean did jive
with reality in terms of how in terms of
how it was made how what we saw how it
operated the materials how it you know
turned on and what was discovered
discovered about it I'm sorry the
migraine is really making it hard for me
to thank you sorry no we we talked that
before the podcast you tell everybody
Bob
getting a migraine I know you're very
stressed out by this is just one of the
reasons why I appreciate you doing this
where was I already we're talking right
the plaintiff and so there was some
paperwork that indicated that this was
from the Zeta Reticuli star system now
yeah now how they obtained that I
haven't I haven't the slightest idea but
it wasn't just from the Zeta Reticuli
star system it was what they called zr3
so it was a third planet in that star
system so there was no other information
about it other than that supposedly
where the craft came from now was that
true I don't know I have no way of
verifying that but that was printed in
the same materials that referenced the
reactor now I looked that stuff up when
I went home and Zeta Reticuli is a
binary star two stars that orbit orbit
one another and it's only visible in the
southern hemisphere and it's about
thirty some-odd light-years away
so that's literally all the information
I have about that I don't know how they
found out it came from there and you
also probably have some suspicions that
they give you some disinformation like
you were talking about before yeah yeah
I mean if you ever decided to talk about
this they added a bunch of nonsense to
make whatever is factual look ridiculous
right or be able to trace it down like
okay this fax came out and you know this
Lazar guy said okay you know came from
Zeta Reticuli so they knew it was when
he read Isaiah reticulate we like what
in the [ __ ] is this well reading all of
the stuff it was what kind of [ __ ] is
this you like why did I sign up for this
no no I would dit to me this was cool
this was interesting I said I was just
excited to be out in a secure area you
know in the middle of the desert is
awesome how old are you I get as in my
20s yeah so you probably totally geeked
out oh yeah it's that this was this was
great I mean I was excited so I didn't
care I'm reading through everything and
so you read through all the Zeta
particularly thing but then when you see
the actual starship with the little
American flag sticker on it
well that was was that later or before
that
that was before so before so you see the
thing before you say oh that's that
before it's hard so many years yeah I
can't either way it doesn't matter the
days have fused together it's so hard to
separate what happened in each visit do
you remember the thought process when
you read that it's from Zeta Reticuli
yeah it it it it didn't hit me like a
ton of bricks or anything is just like
yeah okay [ __ ] I don't know
these were now I don't I mean because
when I read it I hadn't verified
anything and this was just a bunch of
stuff I was reading and I thought maybe
after this they're just gonna give me a
test and see what I can remember and
write crazy information and it would but
like I said when I finally went in with
Barry and had hands-on experience with
what they were talking about it took on
a completely different meaning so
there's a plate there's this thing that
looks like half a basketball and when
it's on you can't come anywhere near it
you can't touch it right how is what is
gravity about that like the concept of
gravity most people's gravity is
bringing something towards it right well
I guess you would say it's anti-gravity
it's gravity shifted 180 degrees it's a
you know antigravity and did they have
any understanding about what could
possibly create this effect did they
have any areas where they'd like you to
look into no they well they knew there
was a fuel source in it and they were
proficient at making it work and again
my analogy to something like this is you
can drop a motorcycle off in the wagon
train days and just leave it with the
keys parked outside you know somebody's
place everybody will come around it and
they'll poke and prod and eventually
they'll turn the key get it to start and
become proficient at writing it yeah but
they won't be able to understand what
the hell's going on they won't be able
to make the plastic fender much less
anything else and I think that's exactly
the state we were at we played around
with the parts long enough before I got
there where they could make the reactor
operate
take the fuel out and know that it makes
it work how exactly what was going on in
the reactor remained a mystery at the
time I think we made some progress on
what was going on inside but I don't
think anybody really knew anything they
could just watch what was going on and
make note of it
how long were there I'd say about six
months or so and what what progress
admit was made while you were there well
we came up with a bunch of reasonably
good ideas about how the reactor worked
and one of them was the base the square
base of it was essentially like a
cyclotron which is a small particle
accelerator a circular one particle
accelerators of linear particle
accelerators are just a you know long
tube essentially in the accelerate
particles with high voltage and you know
radio frequencies till they reach high
speeds but a cyclotron does that in a
small circular area and there's this
very heavy element fuel element 115
something that wasn't on our periodic
charts at the time but it is now it is
now yeah when did it become on the
periodic table now the way their charts
now you know I don't remember do you
remember when they 2004 Durham Germany I
think is where they first advocated for
atoms that lasted 220 milliseconds the
atoms it's nothing right and then later
was discovered a couple more times they
could fabricate it then they gave it
they gave it a place then on the
Periodic Chart
after that called it moscovia so they
told you about this stuff in 1982 yeah
well what what year was this it was 80
88 and 89 when I was there 82 is 182 it
was near Los Alamos I'm sorry yeah so 88
89 they told you about this stuff so
this was not like no they didn't they
didn't tell me about it that's one of
the things that this group came up with
mmm the guy I keep losing my train of
thought with this thing so this one area
this this element 115 was the fuel yeah
it was the fuel that the world will
forgive you for having a migraine yes
really I didn't think that'd give you
more person so I say what yeah
definitely as I said one thing you know
bought for the last 30 years people have
just been on the attack on Bob you know
getting to know him the personal effects
on his life it's really hard to
understand unless you meet his family
and his wife I mean this is the last
thing he wanted to [ __ ] do was have
to talk yeah we should explain that
chairman the you and I had this
conversation I watched a documentary we
had this conversation and I said I have
to talk to him
yeah the document there was there's been
detractors there's been a bunch of
people that called [ __ ] on many of
the things that you've said but over
time many of the things that you talked
about even in the 80s have proven to be
true things that people said we're not
true were proven to be true element 115
was one of them right right right
element 115 the fuel they had was stable
in other words it didn't decay it wasn't
emitting radioactivity when they
synthesized two or three atoms of the
115 it did decay and it was not a stable
element so they're they're kind of two
different things but this is kind of
typical elements always have or pretty
much always have stable isotopes and
unstable isotopes like I think cesium
has like 30 unstable isotopes to it so
all right well hydrogen for example
you're familiar with hydrogen gas it's
stable it's not radioactive but there's
also two other types of hydrogen
deuterium and tritium and deuterium
isn't radioactive it's another stable
isotope of hydrogen but tritium is
radioactive now they're all hydrogen but
they just have different amounts of
neutrons so it's the same thing with
other elements and element 115 depending
on the amount of neutrons it has
designates the isotope but it's 115 they
will continue to take
or experiment and try and make 115 at
different isotopes and I'm sure
eventually they'll come up with a stable
version but it's the taste stable
version that has the properties that
we're talking about so they somehow or
another had acquired a stable version
did they say that the stable version had
come with this crap it absolutely came
with the graft yeah so at the time you
having a firm knowledge of the periodic
chart and knowing what was real and what
wasn't real what was your reaction to
having this stable element 115 that
wasn't even supposed to exist well
everything was impossible right I mean
down down to the metal I I did get a
chance to look inside the craft on only
one occasion and this was important
because where the reactor sat might have
been critical to how it operated since
everything operates without any
interconnections so the placement of
components might be critical so they
allowed me to go inside and and look at
it again I forgot where the hell I am so
you're going into this craft and what
are you thinking when you're inside of
it like what are you seeing it's a it's
a very ominous feeling because it's
there are no at first of all everything
is one color it's like a dark pewter
color and there are no right angles
anywhere it's as if somebody took I've
said this before somebody took a model
out of and fashioned it out of wax and
then heated it just for a short time so
everything melted everything looks like
it's fused together everything has a
radius of curvature were two items meet
it's it's a really weird looking thing
but there was almost nothing other than
a small foldable hatchway that that
looked recognizable everything was uh
was really unworldly to pick on it a way
to describe it so you you get inside
this thing and it's designed for
something that's much smaller than a
human being
yeah you can't really stand up till you
get to the very center of how tall you
I'm five ten
and what do you think this was designed
for I'd say something close to half my
height Wow so these little three-foot
tallest creatures yeah and that the
seats were small too I mean obviously it
was made you know for something
something small but there is no like
there's there's nothing else in there
there's just seats the reactor and some
of the sub components there's no there's
no control panels there's no bathroom
there's no no decorative components or
artwork or anything that you would
recognize or trim I mean it's just a
very bare-bones thing you're not seeing
any screens
well there are archways around it at
that a part of the superstructure and
that one of the archways can become
transparent when I was in there there
was another group working on one of the
archways and you could call that a
screen more or less so through that
archway it would be it would maintain
the solidity the the solid whatever
metal it was yeah but you could just
became transparent yeah I saw that
happen once or twice before I left
did you ask any questions about what the
phone no there's no ask question now but
when you watch something become
transparent and you realize it's still
there but you could now see through it
yeah I mean no that's not that
impressive we do have some liquid
crystal materials that are like that you
know smart glass yeah they call it smart
class so this is just and I don't know
if the craft is made of you know an
advanced metal or a ceramic it was cold
to the touch so um you know I would lean
more towards a metal you're not allowed
to ask questions no the only way work on
the buddy system so I can only exchange
ideas and talk to Barry now this really
interferes with science because science
is based on free discussion and ideally
you get a bunch of guys together
exchange ideas work on problems and
that's how things move forward but
they're so over-the-top concerned about
security they split everything off and
everybody becomes stagnant it it it
destroys any of the progress you can
make or at least makes it go so slow
they I think they wind up shooting
themselves in the foot which is probably
why they arrived at this bottleneck that
they need to get this madman with a
jet-powered Honda come in and see what
he could do I think that was an act of
desperation I think they wanted someone
that's thinks out of the box and let's
just give this guy a try here because
they weren't and they might have done
this four more times since you know up
to the point in time today assuming
they're still working on this thing and
when you see this craft and you're
inside was there any indication that
there was an area that they would use to
control it to pilot was there a pilot
seat whizzers
there were three seats they sat around
the reactor was in the dead center of it
and then equidistant around there were
three seats so that's all the there was
a large you would they're not consoles
there are large rectangular objects also
spaced equidistant around the center
there's nothing on them there's no
button that there's no lights and they
litter all same color this everything is
the same color different shape right and
directly underneath them there's three
levels in the craft the main level is
what we're talking about directly under
that those are the gravity amplifiers
the big rectangular objects underneath
them are the gravity of midders that
look like for lack of a better word a
trash can hanging on a pipe three of
those and then the top layer I this is
just my personal belief I think that has
to do with a navigation or their version
of a computer with some planar panels
sensor panels around the craft that we
would call portholes but they're not
portholes they're just black areas and I
think that just determines its you know
position in space but I was I was in the
center section and I stuck my torso in
the bottom section and hung upside down
so I could see how the gravity
amplifiers were positioned what is they
the roughly the size of this thing it's
I think it I don't
member from being there but after all
the stuff was over I had John Andrews a
guy from the testers model corporation
and you know we sat down and tried to
figure out from what I saw and known
sizes of things and we came up with 52
feet in diameter I think that's always
small yeah so I think that's a fair
reasonable guess now you said there's
nine of them and you got a brief glimpse
at the other ones were they how were
they different Oh
they looked completely different one
looked like I called a jello mold and it
it looked like a classic jello mold with
the rippled sides do it one was a very
flat disc you know like oh I don't like
a straw hat or something like that that
was sitting up on its edge and the thin
part of it had looked like a projectile
had been fired through the edge of it so
I don't know if they were attempting to
see if the metal could be penetrated or
if something or if that's where the
thing came from maybe it was shot down
but that was the only one where I saw
there was you know actual physical
damage to it and that one was roughly
the same size they're all high they were
kind of too far away to tell mm-hmm and
did there was several teams that were
working on the propulsion system so
there was different teams that were
working on these different our aircrafts
I I don't don't know I could only assume
now when you're sitting in this thing
and you're looking at this otherworldly
craft your your goal is to try to figure
out how this thing functions your goal
is to try to figure out how this reactor
I mean he would imagine they would give
you more time than just one day to check
that out oh yeah it wasn't one day right
yeah I mean this is Barry was there
I think Barry was sleeping there I'm
sure they had now that that isn't weird
I mean Oh put the Tonopah test range
where they work on stealth fighters you
know you go I think three weeks on one
week off and you stay up there too so
it's not weird to stay up with the test
site right so yeah you think he prettier
than he
did like he's been up there for a long
time yeah but I'm still there yeah oh no
so you do you have contact with this guy
no oh no I wish I did I kind of thought
he was gonna come out after I did right
and I think I took so much flak and it's
so much [ __ ] for what went on I think I
actually I wound up helping security
there and everybody became afraid of you
know doing or saying anything after that
so what kind of reports did you have to
give like so you're not making much
progress right you're just trying to
figure out what this thing is and it
seems impossible
so well we didn't personally make them I
mean we were always there was never a
lot of information that we gained the
guy you would call him our supervisor or
his name was Dennis Mariani and kind of
a military looking guy and he would
routinely pop in you know during the day
and you know hey what's going on guys
and he would essentially relay any
information anything new we came up with
I mean he was our goal between you know
where we presented him the information
then he took it to wherever they were
you know assembling all the data from
everybody know I assume you're working
normal day so I can eight-hour day no no
no it was really weird that I would be
only called in on certain times in
certain days and they would be weird
hours too
most of the time was later in the
evening I mean I can get a call with 11
o'clock at night and they'll say you
know it's now 11 o'clock by 11:45 you
need to be at McCarran Terminal and you
know we'll let you know when we have
more information but what did you do
while you were there if you're looking
at this object this reactor and you
can't figure out what it is or how it
works other than the fact that works on
this element that we don't even know
about sure I mean the thing was - that
what you do and you know with anything
if you're trying to analyze it all you
can do is perform tests and all we did
is try and come up with every kind of
test we possibly could I mean we tested
you know
it violated a lot of what we thought was
impossible to violate I mean one of the
first laws of thermodynamics I mean
essentially any machine any device that
operates always makes extra heat nothing
works at a hundred percent efficient
even the headphones you're wearing
anything that takes power some of that
power is going to be converted to heat
and it's just wasted this didn't I mean
we looked at back then we had infrared
cameras they're different today but back
then you had a pour liquid nitrogen into
the camera to cool the sensor down and
and get these infrared images you've
seen but it never got no matter what the
load was on the reactor it never got
above ambient temperature which is
impossible I mean you're you know
pulling out huge amounts of power and
nothing ever gets warm
we tried measuring magnetic fields and
there was was nothing there so we
started playing around with the emission
from the emitter is the gravity wave
itself and saw what we could do with it
and how it was focused so we really
spent all our time just trying to see
what the stuff can do and what we can
control so you were seeing what it could
do but you couldn't ever figure out how
it was doing it no not really I mean we
really we really could only use a come
up with a best guess and now I can't say
we really I that I could absolutely
state for certainly very certainty how
anything actually worked now how did you
know at all how they were piloting it
because some they were doing some tests
where they were having these things fly
around in the sky and this is what gets
us deeper into your story
right I was out there for one test right
in fact I was in with Barry in the lab
and Dennis came in and said we're about
to run a test why don't you guys come
out or I think he said Barry wedding
you come out here and bring Bob with you
we went out there and the craft was
already outside the hangar and was just
preparing to lift off now they were in
communication with somebody in the craft
so there was a person in there
yeah there was certainly a person in
there now it's not a comfortable place
to be in because it's small so the guy
has to be sitting on the floor in the
middle my best guess and this is the
same specific craft that you know that
was because you were the that was the
only craft that you were the only one
that I touched and worked on and it it
quietly lifted off the ground which
wasn't incredibly impressive to see
quietly or silently what's well quietly
because it it produced a little Corona
discharge from the bottom a corona
discharge is kind of a high voltage
brush little bluish glow discharge as it
was lifting off the ground you can hear
a slight hiss sound now as soon as it
cleared the ground by about five or ten
feet maybe even less than that the
hissing stopped and the blue go
disappeared so it lifted off quietly and
then it hovered silently if you want to
be specific Wow so then what kind of
maneuvers was it doing it took for that
particular time it took off moved a
little round around to the left and
right and then sat back down the the
craft itself they communicated with it
with a rake because I saw the guy
talking and a regular VHF radio to the
person in the craft and I even saw the
frequency that was on the frequency
counter of the communication the
transceiver there but what's weird is he
shouldn't be able to communicate with
the craft with a radio the radio the
radio waves should Bend around the craft
I mean it shouldn't be possible every
single thing about these the craft and
the way they operated didn't make any
sense to us I mean that's something we
talked about for a while after why
should the frequency Bend around the
craft
well you really have to look at the way
the gravity wave comes out of the craft
as a the reactors in the center and
there's a waveguide that goes up to the
top there's actually a small appendage
that sticks out at the top of the craft
and it produces a heart-shaped
gravitational distortion around the
craft now if the craft is sitting in the
air and you walk underneath it and look
up you actually cannot see the craft the
light bends around it you're bending
gravity bends light it bends radio waves
it's um it it shouldn't be possible to
communicate with a craft that has an
envelope around it that's distorting all
forms of energy but they were apparently
in contact with it somehow or another
through some unexplained way but they
bother explain to you so this thing gets
up it just does some very simple
maneuvers left-right left-right Goes
Down and did they discuss this with you
I mean they said they wanted you to see
it no they just wanted no they didn't
discuss anything with me it said it sat
down we looked around for a bit and
Barry said let's go back we went back in
the lab all we got to do is see it fast
forward to some months later I did have
the test flight schedule of the craft
now they had times they had designated
high performance tests this obviously
wasn't one that was a high performance
test the high performance test went goes
above the mountain range and they do
much more radical moves with the thing
look this is a prized item and they're
not doing anything like taking it out of
the atmosphere or flying around other
countries or anything like this
they just play with this thing right
over the test site but they were doing
some radical moves with it and since I
had the test flight scheduled
statistically the amount of traffic and
the surrounding areas on the highway was
lowest on Wednesdays and that's why
Denny Dennis told us that all the test
flights occurred only on Wednesdays
because it'd be the least chance that
anyone would see what's going on and
this was before the
the government had expanded the
forbidden territory around area 51 and
Papoose Lake and all that stuff right
yeah I think that occurred after my
story came out then people started going
up on the mountaintops and trying to
look down into there
and they kind of freaked out and then
did the land grab and pushed everybody
back but yeah that I think all that
occurred long after I'm sorry that I
came out so you're working there and
while you're working there you're under
this crazy schedule but forgive me for
explaining your story but you would get
these phone calls you would have to go
to the to the airport at 11:00 p.m. and
your wife started thinking that you were
having an affair yeah apparently so now
I did give my permission to have you
know as part of the you know security
clearance process
I gave written permission to have the
phones monitored and things of that sort
so they weren't doing any covert stuff
they you know with any Q clearance tour
which is civilian top secret clearance
or military top secret clearance they go
talk to friends and you know play places
you've been make sure you're not
connected to foreign countries but you
know monitoring your phone is nothing
unusual
however they insisted that you know you
don't even talk to your loved one to
your partner to your wife whatever about
what's going on so she was essentially
in the dark and didn't know the phone
was being monitored well part of the
security clearance is that not only do
you not have any connections to foreign
countries and are in a maniac but you
have to have a stable home life - well
she started having an affair with a
flight instructor now they were
monitoring this on the phone and they
knew it and I didn't so they stopped me
coming in and their attitude at the time
was we need to see how this is going to
play out
and if Lazar is gonna get a little weird
or anything so let's just you know hold
him off from coming in and you
see what happens and they explain this
to you what was happening well after the
fact yeah cuz time kind of went on and
there were guys that were following me
around and I started getting a little
concerned going well [ __ ] they booted
me out of the project and if so they're
not just gonna let me hang out at home
and go get a new job knowing what I know
so as time went on I started getting a
little concerned and I took my closest
friends and just kind of got together I
said hey remember that job I told you
about this is what's going on and like
you don't need to take my word for it
Wednesday night we need to all go out
here I want to show you what's going on
so I took everybody and we went out to
remember since I had the test flight
scheduled and went outside the base out
into the desert and so everybody could
see you know one of the high performance
tests and you know it left quite an
imprint on everybody so they knew I
wasn't and there's videos of these tests
right yeah but remember this isn't that
it's in in the dark in the 80s of the
big monster sized camcorder and you got
you know a bright light jumping around
but yeah I mean we did video of a but
there's no by today's standards it's but
it's your video specifically available
the video that you took
yeah well George Knapp has it it's is it
an argument now do you I have no idea
Jeremy yeah show clips of it in my film
it's it's online and someone did a deep
analysis of it it was interesting to
take a look at how well this microphone
up to face about a fish from your face
right you know to see how his video
looks now but as far as video evidence I
mean we are talking 80s camp words the
most important thing is the human story
here everybody that he took up there on
three separate occasions they don't all
like each other they don't all talk they
all agree on one thing they saw
something that night at the exact point
in time and space that Bob Lazar said
and remember this is 1715 seventy miles
south of area 51 no one even knew really
about area 51 we're talking Papoose Lake
and they all agree they saw something
that night they had never seen before
and they've
ever seen sense right when he said it so
that's one of like the six things where
I'm like how did he know you can dismiss
him I dismiss it but some things we
can't get around and and there's about
five or six of them how did he know
about if Jamie wants to find that video
right now what would you look under Bob
Lazar UFO s for area 51 just kind of
like that so it's like this s for UFO
video bob lazar and god does an analysis
but you're analyzing these 80's videos
he from the very beginning Bob never
said I have proof of my store and I'm
going to tell the world he said at the
very beginning I cannot prove my story
that's not why I'm telling this George
Knapp convinced him to tell people and
he lived to it and I I didn't believe it
either until I talked with George okay
so you you filmed these this test flight
one test flight and then you get caught
actually it was I think the third time
because we went out there the first time
mmm
everybody saw it everybody was amazed
because it did some radical maneuvers
and you know everybody had a lot to say
but new vers that i've seen i've seen
the video it doesn't I don't think
there's something we have now that does
that know in terms of like a human
piloted craft I mean I don't know
obviously with the governor it's
impossible nothing can move like that
and remember we didn't start filming
from the very beginning you know at the
core we were waiting for something you
know to happen the craft took off and I
came flying at a stopped you know turned
it or I angle flew back and then you
know after did some you know amazing
stuff to get the camera and then we
started filming so it doesn't have all
of it on there just has some the way I
describe it to my friends and they said
what is I said take a laser pointer and
then have a wall and then move it around
the wall like you know how it moves
around the wall it doesn't seem like it
has anything to do with inertia or
physics or it's not an impeded in any
way by the atmosphere yeah that's what
it looked at you're essentially
separated from reality as crazy as that
sounds with being in in case its own
gravitational envelope inertia is not
going to affect it and you know this is
this is how some of those recent
sightings would commander David flavor
I'm sure you've heard of this exact you
a UFO I mean he describes exactly that
the thing operates exactly the way I was
describing that's why he was interested
to talk to me but we saw this and you
know on the way home it's like way we
got away with it we should try it again
the next test flight day so this became
a thing to do and I think it was on the
third time that we got caught I mean we
started becoming a little careless I
think we took a Motorhome out there you
know I mean it was like the stupidest
thing you could possibly tell Gaytan
yeah it was ridiculous and again you're
in your 20s yeah and you know what was
funny was we went out there and my
friend Jean Huff and I were leaning on
the front of a vehicle and just for some
reason we just started talking jet like
well I hope they realized that I don't
remember what we were saying but you
know that it's something about attacking
the base or something along those lines
and stealing the craft or something like
that so I'm crazy and then about 20 feet
in front of us we see a little green
light fall on the ground and roll to us
and unbeknownst to us now it's pitch
black you can't see your hand in front
of your face there are a bunch of guards
standing right out there and they had a
night-vision scope where they were like
from here to the wall looking at us
listening to us and the guy dropped it
and the scope rolled over to us and you
could see the green screen we turned the
lights on and all these guys are there
so it was whoa yeah yeah so we did
incredibly stupid stuff and got caught
as we should have because so when they
catch you and they bring you in then
what happens well I went in for
debriefing the following day I went to
Indian Springs Air Force Base which is
kind of a defunct base that they used to
use at the nuclear test site and this is
when they brought out the transcript of
the phone call with my wife
and you know they sat me down and we
said you know when we meant to keep the
secret we meant you can't tell your
friends right you know and it just being
sarcastic and trying to mmm and then
they got real serious but this is where
they you know took the transcript out
and we're reading me what my wife and
you know our friend we're talking about
and it was our dime so what happens from
there what do they do with you
why don't they arrest you I don't think
I don't know I don't know why I'm not
sure they exactly they knew what to do
but they did let me go that night and I
went home and that this is kind of when
the most stressful part started because
you're realizing you're being bombed
yeah no yeah now I know not only am I
being monitored but now I know I'm in
trouble and it wasn't a short time after
that that I contacted you know at that
time the only investigative reporter I
had heard of in Las Vegas was George
Knapp and you know told him some of the
story because I had no idea what the
hell was gonna happen at that point so
George Knapp tries to dissect your story
tries to find holes in it tells it puts
it online and makes everybody aware of
it and that's how I found out about it
yeah to make a long story short well
what happens yet to really make a long
story short what happens from there on I
mean do they contact you and say hey Bob
it's probably a good idea if you shut up
how they try to label you as crazy was
there there a boy there are a lot of
things that happened at you know between
that point I'm leaving out a lot of
stuff to fill in the story we'd have to
go back to Los Alamos and and well I
really don't want to talk about that the
top-secret weapons stuff that you were
working on
no I'm talking about the 115 um well I
don't know I have to think about how
what is the problem I don't want to get
myself into more trouble by admitting
something so I just have to dance around
a couple great just during the filming
of the movie piano but the movies great
by the way thanks Jay and it's on
Netflix right now if anyone who wants to
check it out and if you're one of those
people like me who you know I've always
loved the idea of UFOs I became
extremely weary talking to people who
are UFO believers and UFO fanatics cuz
there's so many of them they're full of
[ __ ] and not just full of [ __ ] they're
they're childishly delirious like the
way they talk about things I mean
there's so many people that are that I'm
in contact they reach me in the night
and they explained to me what we're
doing to the ocean is wrong and like you
know like okay this is one of the
reasons I didn't want to do the show I'm
sure it's no it's I mean it's no joke
we've had people literally camp out on
our front lawn and you know in some ways
I can relate to some of these people you
know maybe some of them did really have
some kind of experience or saw something
and if all their friends think they're
crazy but hey now there's this guy I
heard on the radio and Latinos I'm not
full of [ __ ] so I got to talk to him and
so most of the correspondents I get are
people trying to get a hold of me come
on Bob you you got to listen to me I'm
I'm coming to talk to you I'm you know
I'm driving from Oklahoma or whatever
and and and but some of them are just
[ __ ] batshit crazy I'm yeah they're
frightening there's a lot of
schizophrenic that are involved in the
conspiracy world there's a lot of people
that have real issues Joe I it would be
a disservice to your audience to not say
that we have to look at what's going on
now and understand I've heard on your
show a bunch of stuff about what's going
on now and to not really understand
what's going on now you can't see Bob's
story in the correct light after 30
years and at some point we should just
touch upon that the the biggest being
that things like the tick tock UFO case
that came out I've heard people even on
the show say oh there's a glitch in the
radar that's a data poor
perspective you just don't know yet
what's really going on commander flavor
I was able to get the interview with him
to talk with him way before it became
public I I got that from him he saw it
other pilots saw it this is a big thing
that's going on right now they had more
sightings on the East Coast recently
cubes with with spherical or these are
not aerodynamic and these are the people
we trust to defend us on 9/11
commander favor protected Los Angeles on
9/11 so we trust them but they're not
trained observers radar individuals see
these things and the big the big one
just to throw down so we can consider a
story a little differently there's more
depth to it the big one is the United
States government has admitted that they
have been continuously studying the UFO
phenomenon that program was called a tip
advanced eros or sorry was called AUSA
that that's the mother program George
Knapp got that out they announced
through the New York Times about a tip
but all set these acronyms awesome
advanced aerospace weapon systems
applications program who cares that was
the mother program so they've admitted
we didn't stop studying UFOs in 1969
with Project Blue Book we don't think
it's crazy we're actually want to
reverse engineer the technology that's
why on your other show you said what's
this AAV thing it's like they're making
up another UFO name well hold on there's
a reason because in the documents the
DIA documents that George Knapp released
that everybody said was faked till now
they know is real they call them a AVS
which is advanced aerospace vehicles
people are getting acronyms wrong so
they're the reason for the terminology
change is so that we can mimic what
we're reading in the DIA documents
people can look for that now so they
changed the names to get people away
from UFO or UAP even like Hillary
Clinton said on air right so what he's
talking about Howard grunts I'm Hillary
Clinton informed the public on Jimmy
Kimmel Oh Jimmy we don't call them UFOs
anymore we call them UA AP's
unidentified aerial phenomenon right so
she kind of was giving there the
Clintons are very into the UFO topic
Senator Reid you know he he's done a lot
for the for the subject the study of it
right so she informed the public so they
could look for the right term so these
terms are important because the
dia in those documents they've been
calling them a a vs for quite some time
now and they changed the name to
anomalous no that that's a miss no no so
they always mess around with things but
it's actually advanced right but they're
describing it in the news they were
calling an anomalous vehicle totally and
that's cool they were also saying
anomalous aerospace threats AAT right
because they want the sense of a threat
so my point is all of it if people don't
know this now and they think this stuff
is is fantasy this this part of it that
we're studying it that we take it
seriously we're spending money on it and
that we're getting great data from from
visual pilots to to radar that's why we
know it's aerospace they dropped from
80,000 feet but guess what that's the
top scope of the spy-1 radar is 80,000
feet so the radar system they were using
it was coming from above that so my
point is this if you don't understand
that this is happening you're just
behind the curve because you don't have
the information because of the stigma
that you're talking about I saw you get
totally upset with UFO topic I met you
first when you get totally upset with
UFO topic it's the people when when
you're doing your I'm sorry man when
you're when you're doing your show you
know the jargon questions everything I
could see how how frustrating is trust
me I have been frustrated too how
luckily my mentors George Knapp and he's
taught me the Pitts Paul pitfalls as I
went through it my whole point in this
rant right here is just that we have to
now look at Bob's story but knowing the
facts not someone saying it's a bird
it's a plane it's a glitch they're not
and so if you don't know that you just
don't have the information yeah I'm not
just that knowing the facts as we know
him in 2019 not 1988 absolutely and so
what is he said that has come true he's
totally unimpressed with it right what
does he said this come true so I was
like Bob they've announced gravity as a
wave you were right and you're
vindicated and he looks at mean he's
like well if you think about it Jeremy I
had like a 50-50 chance he was not very
impressed right when did they announce
gravity as a wave so they detected in a
sense they attempted gravity waves now
who is they
you might know more there's two black
holes that were colliding and that's how
they were able to detect yeah somebody
bill I don't know which group it was or
what part of the government
that's what Google's fourth yeah what it
but they you know built a gigantic
gravity wave detector and pretty much
detected that there are such things as
first observation of gravitational waves
it says it was in 2016
ok the first observation of
gravitational waves was made on 14th of
September 2015 rather as announced by
the Li geo and Virgo collaborators on
11th of February 2016
previously gravitational waves had only
been inferred indirectly via their
effect on the timing of pulsars in
binary star systems Danton
Tom the wave form connected by both Li
geo LIGO observatories master
predictions of general relativity for
gravity for a gravitational wave
emanating from the inwards I'm trying to
get this from the inward spiral and
merger of a pair of black holes around
36 and 29 solar masses and the
subsequent ring down of the single
resulting black hole well that I mean
yes no he was on in the 80s the
predominant theory was gravity is
produced by gravitons okay you know part
of theoretical particles but they're not
they're waves they're not particles and
that's so the thought is that the way we
experience gravity it's based on mass
which is why the moon which is roughly
one-quarter the size of the earth has
1/6 of the Earth's gravity so there's
some sort of a computation you can make
based on mass right and and remember we
can observe the effects of gravity but
we have no idea what it is all we can do
is observe it and we can't make it the
only way you can make gravity is just
put more mass together it's just a
product of gravity but if you can make a
if you have a machine that makes gravity
you can pretty much do anything you can
affect time you can have force field all
that stuff that's inside
fiction becomes reality if you have a
machine that can make gravity and what
we worked on in the desert was a machine
that makes gravity I love your analogy
of dropping off a small nuclear reactor
to the Victorian era I love that that
analogy because back then that was
impossible that was magic but you're
talking about here the fact that they
just discovered this four years ago that
this is a wave but we're as much as we
know and as impressed as we are as we
should be with how much more
technologically advanced we are than
every other creature on this planet
we're still in many ways in the
adolescence of technological innovation
absolutely absolutely
if even adolescence and when you're
talking about this binary star system
Zeta Reticuli and who knows how much
longer these things have been around
than us who knows what their
evolutionary cycles been who knows what
I mean we might be talking about
something that's a million years more
advanced than us yeah yeah it could
easily be now I'm not in believe it or
not I'm not into UFOs I don't follow
stories or you know even after your
experiences no I'm fascinated with the
technology and I it really it works me
like every night I go to sleep that you
know I don't that it was my own doing
essentially that that prevented me from
continuing on in the in the project I
mean it's a that to be on that cutting
edge of technology is so alluring to me
right but you know by the same token I
don't really care that there's aliens or
where they come from I mean the prize is
the technology and that's what I'm
fascinated by but so I don't listen to
UFO stories and that sort of thing but
George Knapp is I mean he's the guy that
has the contacts and tries to thread
everything together and what he recently
told me as he found I don't know is
either documentation or people that he
spoke to it's at this the existence of
this project the project that I was on
it's something that they seemed to take
out every eight or ten years so that's a
very specific memo and
this is actually I this is the first
time I'll be very clear with people
about it it's a big topic of
conversation right now it's called the
Wilson memo you can look it up
Admiral Wilson met with a scientist
who's actually was featured in one of my
films
everybody has been debating whether or
not this document of a conversation with
a with an sitting Admiral at the time is
a real document it's an actual
conversation that happened and this
document is right but he wants to know
the world is going crazy right now in
the UFO world I'll tell you straight up
right now I'm in the position to know
and it is a real document that it is
real so the conversation you read in
that that conversation was had I can't
attest to every you're not being very
clear sure please no problem so there
was a document is circulating right now
that is really big it's going around
everywhere people are asking what is
this document it's called the Wilson
memo is what how you can find it online
though or the Wilson leak there's
Jimmy's got it the Wilson memorandum use
of human vu Admiral Wilson meets with
this scientist and they have this
discussion oddly enough that special
projects at EG&G and if I remember the
document from 2001 I'm telling everybody
right now it's real and we'll see my
history is pretty good would like to say
and if something is real or not right so
here we go the document comes out they
meet at EG&G special projects in 1989
they stumble into a problem this happens
they put the technology away and then
they bring it back out and see if the
material science has caught up and if
they can make any progress so this
document kind of talks about this
process the big thing I get from it and
a lot of its vindicating to Bob and one
of the things that's vindicating besides
the EG&G thing is that private industry
so this guy's an admiral and he says I
found out about your essay P your
special access program I need to know
about it and he's going to a a private
part of Industry and he is denied access
and he says uh you know I should be
running this program and they were able
to deny him access so I think the
takeaway here is
get out I'm telling you that that is an
actual correct that is a leak now
everything said in that document and I
don't know what are you talking about
what what is said in that document it's
it's a between a scientist and an
admiral that are sitting and they're
having a meeting and they're talking
about the the search for the the UFO
subject the search to get special access
program access to all of these different
things like reverse engineering programs
so in this document they talk about it I
believe that the this document that the
person that went was employed by Robert
Bigelow you know one of the guys has a
couple of orbiting satellites and all
that stuff he's a guy owned skinwalker
ranch no he's not he was the guy okay
yeah he used to own it there's a new
owner and I interview him for my other
film but there's a new owner and you'll
be hearing a lot more about that soon
but uh like it'll just there's their
stuff that you'll be hearing about
skinwalker ranch soon because there's a
new owner anyway the whole point of this
in you know insertion here is just that
that document kind of validates a lot of
this idea Bob just said that they make a
little progress then they can't go
anywhere they tuck it away and then they
bring it back out you know ten years
later and start working on it what is
the limiting factor I think Bob should
speak on this but it's the material
science yeah it's really where physics
is so I can I can see them doing that I
mean I didn't have any information on
that but I think what you know Georgia
uncovered is probably accurate that you
know we try and do what we can and once
we reach a roadblock on we really can't
figure it out it's just friggin wait put
the thing away wait for science to catch
up and you know a decade later let's
take the project out again and see all
right now where can we go but there's
got to be someone who remains informed
right oh yeah I've got your scientists
like you and Barry you got you people
that you compartmentalize you've got
these people working there has to be
some people right that know everything
you've got security and then someone's
gonna be on the outside saying hey we
need people to guard this building don't
let anybody in for 10 years I said yeah
I think a lot of that is private
industry and I think that's how they
keep it yeah I think that's how they
litter pick
the government is just so leaky I think
that's kind of what their dough is what
the document kind of proves you just
articulated that that it is in control
private industry what private industry
some aerospace company something I don't
know yeah they wouldn't they would the
guy would the Admiral wouldn't name it
in the car in the conversation yeah so
they still have these things supposedly
I would guess I mean I don't have any
information have you ever asked anyone
that has any inkling of any idea of
where they got them or how they got them
no but something must have been said to
me from Barry and but I Ike it was just
too long ago and I I can't quite
remember it was said but it it just left
a seed in my mind I think at least one
of them was part of an archeological dig
so it's old something one at least one
of them is old I don't know if it was
the one I worked on but I remember
something to do with an archaeological
dig whoa so that's that means it's not
just old it's ancient they'll be a great
Steven Spielberg movie as all of it
would yeah that came out when he said
that for the first time no that's a
freak out right yeah Harrods with some
brushes looking for a Tyrannosaurus Rex
bone hit metal and when did they find it
you know that they have nine of them
well and how could we have not heard
about that what about the guys with the
brushes how could you uncover something
like that and with Joe's newspaper at
home does I mean they said it on that
first day oh you mean the Roswell yeah
yeah I have a cover
what is this is the document but I had
to do some digging to find it yes it's
just kind of yes so this is where they
meet at EG&G and this is Admiral Wilson
and there's a lot more coming out now I
want to be clear George didn't put this
out he didn't leak this out enemy this
is I can tell you how I courted this
this conversation so this was an
employee of at the time Robert Bigelow
and this is in 2002 right you remember
when he had that government contract
called hop the world all knows about now
and he had knids it studied the ranch
that 22 million everybody is saying it
was for a tip advanced aerospace
identification program the 22 million
dollars was for all SAP that was pushed
through through Congress three
congressmen right an astronaut it was
pushed through and that's what that 22
million dollars by the way they spend
more money on viagra every year than
they do studying UFOs if it was just
this program which I think is funny more
money from France they probably do them
UFOs well you never know how it seeds in
a population but anyway this program
this is what was the mother program so
it it got the 22 million and really it
was to study skinwalker ranch oddly
enough that 22 million all was inspired
by the phenomenon they were seen at
skinwalker ranch because the scientists
they're seeing vehicles come through
like a space in the sky yeah we went
there I went yeah you interviewed a
bunch of people that seemed full of [ __ ]
but a couple didn't but this very very
interesting totally and there's a bit in
if you look I spent a lot of time in the
area I'm not talking about those stories
I'm saying there were scientists hired
by the government right through Bigelow
to study the ranch because they thought
it was important and you know whatever
whatever the point is that 22 million
was to study that then we have a tip
which is like an auxilary kind of
program of military settings that
commander flavors and that sort of thing
this document is just one of those
things that has now come forward that
through the Bigelow studies it was
government funded with and then it was
personally funded and then government
funded it's just one of those things
that kind of shakes you because you got
this military guy who can't get access
because of the private industry that's
holding these non-terrestrial materials
that they can't study it so that's the
the claim right now give it some time
let people dig more into this it's
fascinating man so you are essentially
you're you're you're kicked out right
you're you're out of the this program
you can't work with these crafts anymore
and do they give you any threats do they
tell you what you have to do from here
on out yeah well I mean the way it ended
was I told George Knapp all this stuff
and you know he said well let's
just get it on tape should something
happen at least we have a record of it
and I don't remember what the impetus
was but at some point George wanted to
air it and he said you know you make the
call on it and look if at any point you
change your mind
we won't air it and it came down to the
day where George wants to put her on the
five o'clock news he said this is
important stuff people have to know
about it and I thought it was too I said
it's kind of a crime I know you got to
keep the technology secret but you can't
not tell everybody that this stuff is
going on that we have you know actual
hardware from another civilization it's
a big [ __ ] deal you know probably the
biggest one there ever was and George
said you know today's the day we got to
put it on the news or something to that
effect and when it came right down to
the time to air it I changed my mind and
I said we're not doing it and that's
what turned into the famous wrestling
match between me and George trying to
get the tape but he won because he was a
bigger guy so you're actually physically
wrestled well I think it was more of a
pulling match we were I don't think we
ever hit the ground but he got the tape
put it in the player and boom five
o'clock news was on and then I got a
call after that and they said it was
from Dennis he said you have any idea
what we're gonna do to you now and he
hung up the phone that was the last
communication I had with him and what
has happened to you since then after
that a lot of people I've known either
were audited by the IRS people had
anybody I know that had clearances that
worked in secure programs had the
clearances pulled one of them friendly
one of mine that Jeremy knows he's got
on camera with me soon he'll tell the
story now that he's out of work up there
he was working up at the Tonopah test
range waiting for his clearance to come
through and you know they they pulled
that it would it became it's like if
they can't get the person that's
involved they just create a problem for
everybody that surrounds them
and so I mean the way it turns out it
hurt a lot of people's lives that I was
connected to and that's an effective way
of shutting someone up so you feel that
by coming forward and going public that
couldn't just snuff you out that was I
mean that's what I was told and George
and everybody you know said that you
care no it's you know since it's public
there's you know no one will touch you
and I you know I I fell for it and I
wish you didn't yeah sometimes sometimes
when it's just over stress and people
camp it on your lawn yeah but it's this
is gonna make things worse doing this no
does not make things better tell them
how is this gonna make things better
because you're getting a real chance to
explain yourself in a way that's going
to make people who are not only work in
the government people that are police
officers and firefighters and first
responders and doctors and scientists
they're going to emphasize emphasize
empathize and and empathize with what it
must be like to be a person like you in
your 20s who gets thrust into this world
unknowingly and confronted with one of
the most if not the most important
discovery in the history of human beings
the big question are we alone it's the
number one question there's two
questions right what happens when we die
and are we alone those are the two big
questions right and if we're not alone
and someone knows we're not alone and
these some people who know we're not
alone are these bungling sort of even if
they weren't it's a crime yet they're
not telling the rest of us but I mean I
don't mean bungling in terms they're
incompetent
I mean they can't be competent it seems
to me to what you're describing that no
one can be competent with this
technology like the victory Victorian
era scholars analyzing some sort of a
nuclear reactor there's there's no way
why do you think why do you think
they're not telling us let's just make
assumption that this is true right now
why do you think that they're not
telling us that our government doesn't
tell us what's your best well
let me put it in the it would you do if
I'm the president okay and I get this
information what do I do with this what
do I do this there's something that we
don't know there's something we don't
understand there's something that came
from another world we got it tucked away
in the mountains and I just want you
guys to know about it
hey sleep tight hey American Idol is on
tonight who you thinks gonna win yeah
who's gonna win another one is
uncertainty and the other one is what
Bob and I've talked about a lot
absolutely
not knowing what to tell people because
you don't really understand it yourself
even right God what do you say you if
you want to run a government you want to
get people to pay their tax and there's
something else yeah you says you have
these objects fine with impunity right
and yes someone else well not only that
what can you say like how much do you
really know I think it's mainly the tech
knowledge that they just want to keep
the technology secret because there's
yeah whoever gets this yeah you you
control the where you become you
literally become invincible once you
master the technology you can't you
cannot penetrate a field like that so I
imagine that's I know it's all science
fiction but science fiction turns into
science fact if you have real force
fields around aircraft in battleships
you you win you win you can force your
will upon anybody and like I said
there's so much more to the story when I
was first there there were Russian
scientists at s4 that was this was early
on in the project this was before
Operation Paperclip became public as
well right I would imagine that was I
don't know what the dates when was it
when did that was 98 I think yeah yeah I
don't know the dates on roughly ten
years later Operation Paperclip becomes
Freedom of Information Act we say that
Russia and that Germany he's have a
Russian scientists yeah but I mean
Russian scientists a lot of them came
from Germany a lot of those those rocket
scientists that work with NASA they all
came from Nazi scientists got it so some
Russians got some of them I just know at
some point there was intense cooperation
with Raymond even exchanging some ideas
on nuclear weapons and you know EMP
tests and some things we would never
have discussed with them but at the same
time it was in the late 80s they were
involved
actually in the area at s4 with us and
guts communicate with these guys are you
solving no I knew they were there berry
berry would talk about the commies that
were there the counties and that was
back when they were the Commons yes
there were real commies and at some
point it wasn't our group but at some
point there was a big discovery made and
this did not happen when I was there it
happened in between my trips to there
and after that apparently they decided
it was just too cool to share with
anybody and the Russians were never
allowed back on the base after that but
you don't know what that discovery was
no no I said it wasn't my group so one
of the other groups really found out
something but the you know in typical
American fashion is all right this as
our as you guys get the hell out here
was there any inkling that any other
government had something similar
no no nothing that I had her see that
was the thing that always freaked me out
was why if if something was so superior
to human beings it's almost like
visiting an ant colony like why would
you go to the Queen I don't give a [ __ ]
who the queen is I'm a human I'm so
superior to you ants I don't care who
you have running your hive I'm just
gonna study it I think it's who got it
who got it look at the you know rocket
technology in Germany but they got nine
of them yeah that doesn't make sense to
me either so they were either in the
same area or you know one had clues to
where others were I mean I don't know
you you have to fill that in there but
you're right I mean nine of them that's
a that that's a a big dig if it was
archeological well one of the more
recent the recent sightings and these
discussions that have been coming out
recently from Air Force pilots and Navy
pilots they've been talking about things
happening in the ocean and that that
something go literally goes into the
water or something maybe below the
surface think about water 2004 tick-tack
Nimitz case so that's when George Knapp
and I broke on the radio twice before
the New York Times said no this one
really well commander favor and those
pilots there was a disturbance on the
surface of the water
commander flavor visually saw what
looked like similar to
across some object so it's like as if
you have some a coral under the water
and you've got it's breaking over right
the tic-tac is doing this crazy maneuver
that defies it's a gravity propelled
says they saw it in the sky before they
saw in the water right yeah so there
were there were radar that was picking
this these things coming down from
80,000 feet drop into 50 feet in less
than a second this is it this is
actually on the news today there was a
briefing so a lot of people get this
confused I did not this one none either
no so that is called the gimbal so
there's three videos released by the
Pentagon that are all after shoe light
and keep the volume on fire
I would I would really just pay
attention to the source video so you've
got the tic-tac which is this object the
commander flavor saw another pilot
filmed it with a FLIR pod and it goes to
but this one you see is really important
to Bob's story the gimbal craft it's
been recently analyzed it's FLIR not
only does it its definitive that it's
not conventional anything by the by its
movements but there's a pocket of cold
air around a propulsion source so this
object by the way sat stationary for
days if not weeks it's at stationary you
know they found it 11 hours later and
they were saying there's no way this
thing using that kind of energy to go
that fast could just hover the amount of
time and by the way you're seeing a very
small part of what happened that day
this object was not alone and so
hopefully that information comes out and
we can I mean I wish we had video of it
I'm sure we'd all want to see it but
that's called the gimbal that was East
Coast right 2015 West Coast 2004 was the
tick-tack the disturbance on the water
commander flavor believes there was
something under that water that was
causing that disturbance when the
tic-tock was coming around to do in it
with inside the the people that are
studying this they're thinking maybe the
tic-tac system was causing the
disturbance but the USO unidentified
submerged object that he visually saw
the whole interesting thing about that
is I would love Bob to describe it is
why it doesn't matter if these craft are
in space air or water why doesn't it
matter I love when he talks about this
[ __ ]
well first of all commander flavor was
the f-18 pilot off the Nimitz that was
sent out to find out what this stuff is
but and it wasn't just I got a chance to
talk to him recently and it wasn't just
a radar image
I mean commander flavor had eyes on it
for over five minutes watching this
thing as four other pilots did so this
wasn't a radar blip or anything I mean
these guys were watching this thing but
you know one of the things I think in
the gimbal video the way the craft that
we worked on flies is it doesn't fly
like conventional aircraft does and it
doesn't fly like a flying saucer Witter
in a 1950s movie it flies belly-first
I mean it may set down conventionally
but it always rotates it doesn't roll
maneuver puts its belly towards the
target and then moves your car flying
with the wheels forward right right I
mean it may lift it land on the wheels
but at some point when it wants to leave
the flips up points the wheels where it
wants to go and takes off and the gimbal
video you can see the craft do the roll
maneuver and it's really interesting it
behaves exactly like the craft that I
worked on so much like we have different
shaped aircrafts and fighter jets and
cars they probably have different shapes
of these objects that operate under
similar principles right but they all
have the same power source all the same
power source and we're also dealing with
if you think about the laws of
technological progression you know you
think of Moore's law and you think of
how things accelerate you've got to
think that if this civilization is who
knows how many years more advanced than
we are if not even years I mean I mean
we're thinking about in terms of
conventional terms right the way the way
we look at the world I mean they may be
they might be just superior in terms of
their intellect they've gotta be maybe
maybe we don't know well the only reason
I I say that is because look everyone
doesn't necessarily start at
steam engine right and go to an internal
combustion engine and then you know
electric power nuclear power and go up
the ladder that we right can't weigh on
you know the binary if the stuff is true
about the origin and the binary star
system and they have heavier elements
that we don't have and this element
stable element 115 is a naturally
occurring material maybe that's the
first thing they started experimenting
with and the version of their steam
engine their first product was something
that operated like this and actually
when they came to earth to look around
or you know whatever they were amazed at
the stuff we were doing these guys
burned stuff and squirted out the back
to go forward so right um right you know
who says they follow any kind of normal
progression like that
my thought was if you went back to the
1400s and then you went from 1400 to
1500 you're not gonna see that much of a
difference technologically right if you
go from 2,000 to 3,000 I assume there's
going to be a radical change right well
they yeah the Delta the rate of change
is is magnificently higher than it used
to be right so if you think about what
they had in 1988 and you think about
what they probably have in 2019 just
logically seems like they would advance
I would think so the only question is
like are they living is that a living
thing in terms of like a biological
thing or are they some sort of an
artificially created creation like we
are working on right now I mean we're in
the middle of working on artificial
reality artificial being sentient beings
artificial intelligence there's constant
there's silicon-based life forms that
they're essentially trying to create
Boston dinette
was it Boston Dynamics of the company's
robot robots
yeah you can make machines out of flesh
right so a cyborg or cybernetic organism
is just that you know that's what a lot
of people think those like gray things
or you know that people call the greys
you know it's like they were like their
machines rented from flesh so what
you're saying is like just no synthetic
like they don't even need to be you know
machines well they seem to have no sex
organs where they're described by people
that have had interactions
with them assume these people aren't
lying right or crazy or whatever right
that they have no sex organs and that
they don't seem to have any muscle
there's almost like a frame right and
they have enormous heads I mean if you
look at Australia Pittacus or depictions
of you know ancient hominids and then
you go to human beings one of the things
you see is bigger heads and weaker
bodies well you see some clear
progression of evolution you know where
or something like that I would lean
towards synthetic organism because it
looks like it was made for a specific
task there's no reproductive organs so I
mean that almost kind of leaves out any
kind of you know physical evolution
right well that's also the bottleneck
right our bottleneck is our biological
imperative the the need to breed
emotions fear anxiety all these
different things that exist in order to
force us into making sure we reproduce I
mean that's essentially there's a human
reward systems that aren't necessary
once they can figure out a way to make
some sort of sentient artificial life
some sort of thing that doesn't have
these biological limitations that we
have by the way these crafts all these
different kinds have been reported
because it was confusing I always
thought of flying saucers what I heard
Bob Lazar talk about Flying Saucer right
but if you look back in history people
have always reported the weirdest shapes
like none of them are alike you know
there there are other saucers but you
got cigar shaped you got you know the
top hatching you have orbs why maybe
they're serving different purposes
they're doing different things like we'd
use different tools and I want to be
clear the reason I know that memo is is
real is because I spend a lot of time
with dr. Edgar Mitchell a six man to
walk on the moon last guy to film before
he died right that's how I know I don't
want any journalists thinking I got it
from anywhere else I know because of dr.
Mitchell and he said the same thing
maybe these things are performing
different tasks you know and that's what
I seen if you if you think about what an
alien is in terms of our are the sort of
iconic image of an alien like the Steven
Spielberg Close Encounters of the third
time the Third Kind alien they seem like
what we'd assume a human being would
eventually become right and if these
things are tied
human beings are smaller than they've
ever been before the weaker than they've
ever been before and there seems to be a
trend in that direction and this trend
seems to be amplified by our
technological progression there are a
lack of need for muscle strength and our
lack of need for violence and we're
moving in a society to try to get away
from all the things that we think or a
bore and about human beings and the
terrible behaviors that we have if we
one day do give birth to some sort of an
artificial being like Marshall McLuhan's
quote we are the sex organs of the
Machine world you know that one day we
all buy this yeah McLuhan was brilliant
and that that quote has always been one
of my favorites because okay what are we
doing when we were constantly
technologically innovating we're
constantly looking for faster cars
better computers bigger screens faster
more resolution more pixels more this
more that higher bandwidth five G 10 G
right what are we doing we're moving
into this in this if you just follow it
objectively stay stand back
don't attach yourself or your
civilization your culture to it and look
at what it is we're moving a hundred
percent towards technological innovation
if you looked at this species from afar
and if you weren't a part of it you
would say what does this species do oh
they make things they make things better
every year
beehives the same [ __ ] thing that you
see ten years ago you go by see a bee hi
it's amazing it's cool but they're the
same [ __ ] thing they figured out how
to do it they make a beehive right we
don't do that we make better things what
would you constantly and at some point I
think that technology is gonna fuse with
us yes and we're gonna because already
happening yeah Yvan must talked about it
on my podcast that we are cyborgs you
just carry it in your pocket it's a
phone it answers any question you want
you couldn't talk to it it'll give you
the answers into the answers
instantaneously it navigates you it has
all your phone numbers in it has all
your contacts you can get a hold of
people people listening to you through
it
it's connecting us in ways even
involuntarily haptics that kind of yeah
it's also getting on your wrist how many
people have I watches Apple watch is it
all right the rest right and that's only
because we can't integrate them yet but
if you know that point it's kind of
percent yeah I didn't joke about it last
night but I have a bit about it that I
do about the integration between humans
and technology
what would you do if you are a hyper
intelligence right would you do the work
yourself or would you create some cool
things called like humans to do it for
you would you create things that are
cybernetic organisms to come in with
machines and do it for you if you're a
hyper intelligence that has kind of
changed like you've described
you'd probably create workers right well
that's a vast conspiracy theory I'm not
talking about conspiracy but it is a
kind of a conspiracy I'm asking you well
I mean I don't think it's necessarily
that I mean you could look at it that
way but that is the way a conspiracy
theorist would look at it the way I
would look at it is like there's
obviously a progression going on a
biological progression there's some sort
of an integration with technology
there's some sort of imperative this
need for technological innovation it's
inescapable everyone has it and I think
it's attached to materialism and some
sort of a strange way because so many
people work so hard to get new things
and like God that seems so illogical and
preposterous and it makes people unhappy
and depressions on the rise but nobody
seems to be able to stop it like why is
that well maybe it's because we are the
electronic caterpillars that give birth
to the butterfly
maybe that's what we're doing very well
but our job is to do is to make some
sort of a cocoon and we don't even know
we're doing it while we're doing it do
you think a caterpillar as well hey
caterpillar what are you doing man just
doing my thing it's my job I have to
make this could be a natural part of
evolution it could be that right just
supposed to do this and make the jump to
some sort of mechanized right yeah
an orangutan that is fishing with a
spear no they've figured out how to fish
with Spears there's there's some
primatologist without somebody showing
them how to fish no they've imitated
human beings doing it and now they do it
but they do it independently they're not
trained orangutans they're wild rank
believe that there's a wild ratts
impressive well there's these
primatologist I guess you would call
them primatologist that's a term that's
a great biologist biologists that
believe that monkeys and chimps and some
of the great apes are moving into the
Stone Age that they've currently entered
the Stone Age like they're not
staying what they were a hundred
thousand years ago or five hundred
thousand years ago but they're actively
using tools and they're experimenting
with different different ways to use
those tools and then they're making
tools out of stone they're making these
tools out of sticks and they're using
them well this might just be what
happens this might just be what happens
I mean why else why would why the [ __ ]
we work so hard I mean I was I was
driving to LA this morning I had a
doctor's appointment so I was on the 405
at 8:00 in the morning but Jesus Christ
like this is so crazy
when you're in the 405 in LA at 8
o'clock in the morning you see literally
a million cars and it's just everywhere
you go it's people but and also I'm in a
Tesla so I have it on autopilot so I'm
there sitting I'm listening to a podcast
I barely have my hand on the wheel I'm
not touching [ __ ] this cars driving me
along I'm not even doing anything I'm
just I'm just hanging out it's so much
less stress do it that way right so it
encourages you to innovate it encourages
you to embrace this new technology I got
this giant screen it's showing me the
navigation in front of me Oh
be there five minutes early excellent
and I'm listening to a podcast
wirelessly it's Bluetooth screen
streaming from my phone and I pulled
that podcast which came out today out of
the [ __ ] sky and I'm listening to it
and I'm all comfortable in my nice
little car just driving on my way to the
doctor's office this is irresistible
stuff yeah yeah it's frightening ly
irresistible but is it frightening I
mean if you were a monkey or if you were
an Australia Pittacus would you go man I
don't want to [ __ ] be a person I live
in a house that's [ __ ] I like just
swinging around on trees I like running
from Jaguars this is life guys life is
running from crocodiles it's not living
in the [ __ ] suburban oh there's
probably some letter like that yeah I
don't think so I think I think what when
it comes we're gonna embrace it we're
gonna embrace it the same way embrace
cellphones the same way embrace
television there's gonna be a few
holdouts I don't even know an email
address man those although there's a few
and far between there good luck with
that [ __ ] go move to the woods Ted
Kaczynski yeah I was just gonna throw
Ted Kaczynski was right this is
something that I think about sometimes
when I get really
that Ted Kaczynski was a part of the
Harvard LSD studies this has been proven
Ted Kaczynski they cooked his [ __ ]
brain when he was at Harvard and then
when he went over to Berkeley and became
a professor his goal was to make enough
money so that he could to implement this
program and live in the woods and then
write his manifesto and start killing
people that were involved in propagating
technology he was expunged from the
Harvard logs by the way this is
something my friend just called me about
so there's like this private library and
they used to print people's names
whenever they were part of a university
and he was one of the handful of people
that were expunged from it I want to
jump back to the one thing Joe I don't
want to be very careful with that word
conspiracy theorist what I was what I
was saying to you was we terraform our
earth right we tariffs when we change
the environment we do all this
innovation what is stopping us from
thinking that that's not being done I'm
not saying it is I'm saying what's
stopping us from thinking that that's
being done on a much bigger level on a
cosmic level
you mean like aliens coming down doing
that to humans so I'm telling you that
there is something here that's there's a
fact you know there's something there
are craft they're here they're not ours
they're here so the question is what is
that about and I'm just looking at what
we do with what you're describing with
technology I think it's much more likely
that the same way we observe chimps and
we observe that they are now in the
Stone Age that they're observing us and
that they're recognizing that there is a
pattern that there is a there's a steps
that happened I mean Carl Sagan talked
about the different levels of
civilization and then you know if we
don't get past certain levels we're
never going to reach this I mean we're
in civilization gonna stay type zero
well we're in this warring polluting
yeah pillaging were awesome
civilizations
well we're awesome in a lot of ways you
know but in that way we're not well yeah
where were children that have immense
power that we didn't really the other
thing is you're using the immense power
that other people have created right I
mean even when you're driving a car you
stomp it on the gas like whoo you didn't
invent the [ __ ] engine you didn't
invent tires there's all these things
that were involved in the creation of
this thing that is really outside of
your
grasp of understanding but yet you have
the ability to use it like a person with
a gun I'm just gonna bang bang bang
people you don't you didn't invent a gun
so like you've you've without the
intellect to craft and engineer and in
and manifest these creations you just
have access to them because you have
paper or your Bitcoin or whatever the
[ __ ] you're using using a credit card
now you have almost no responsibility
you just you could just flippantly use
these things which is why we you know we
were very childlike in our actions
because we haven't had to earn the
responsibility we haven't had to earn
these things that we've been able to
have and you've only been able to have
them because other people have innovated
and spent ungodly amounts of time and
effort and focus in the lab to create
these things and then they've all put
them together and then what is the
what's the reason to put them together
to profit well what's the reason to
profit well why are you doing this so
you can buy more things well what are we
doing what are we doing we're making
better things that's what we do that's
all that's all we do is make better yeah
why the [ __ ] do we need oil why do we
need oil why can't we just burn wood and
stay home why can't we grow chickens and
food in the backyard why can't we do
what we [ __ ] can we certainly can
people do do it but we decide to make
that almost impossible our preferred way
of living is to stuff everyone into a
very small area where no one grows
anything other than weed this is what la
is la is 20 million people with hard
surfaces ISM is many hard surfaces you
can boy if you got an acre backyard now
a holy [ __ ] look at all that grain this
is amazing no that's the [ __ ] earth
coming through this weird sort of
creation that we've put on top of the
earth but the goal is that like New York
City that's there's none of it right you
just got you've got Central Park and
they just got human [ __ ]
you've stacked up no one's growing
anything and then constant work
everyone's up early go go go innovate
progress make that money so you can buy
more things and every year hey Apple
where's this [ __ ] new phone as if
your phone isn't good around yeah
phone's taking pictures and videos and
people are calling
you when you got applications to tell
you which way the winds blowing it's not
gonna blink of an eye blink of an eye
it's all gone though that you know like
ten thousand years and the Hoover Dam
goes or whatever you know Mount Rushmore
disintegrates so it's amazing because we
have created that and and everything's
trying to spring up through that we keep
it maintenance down but we're we're a
blink man something hits but we don't
think that way well you know you think
in terms of your own life right you
think in terms of what you want and what
you need right now you know what it's we
are in many ways this combination of
this weird primitive ape-like thing with
the ability to calculate and manipulate
our world in our environment that makes
us holy unique on top of that with
existential angst and and and fear so
what do you do with that with [ __ ]
water down with the pre antidepressants
give these [ __ ] people some [ __ ] that
keeps them moving well they're worried
about the future they're trying to
figure out what reality is it's just
you're on a goddamn convertible
spaceship spending a thousand miles an
hour hurling through infinity there's no
meaning to this thing just keep making
[ __ ] keep making stuff and then one day
they're gonna be able to hit that switch
and this life will be born out of
innovation and thinking and progress and
technology and more than likely it's
probably going to be what we're seeing
that these things are that you're you're
observing mm-hmm I'm not observing them
but yeah some ones are you implying that
they're us I don't think they are us but
I think they are what happens when
things keep going it's not us just like
we're not monkeys right all right I'm
not a chimp oh that's a cool like
they're from here is your idea no no no
that this is what happens all over the
union right yeah this is what happened
here's the thing you know I went to see
Brian Cox's he has this amazing live
show with Robin ence where they have
these LED screens he's huge screens with
high resolution depictions of the cosmos
and one of the most mind-blowing things
was he has this large-scale image of the
universe and it shows all the individual
galaxies of the universe and it just
keeps moving through all these galaxies
in three dimensions
and it's [ __ ] incredible but what's
stunning is the relative uniformity of
it even at you know I mean you're
obviously looking at an incredibly small
depiction of something that's immensely
large like a galaxy of hundreds of
billions of stars you're seeing it as
this little dot but this little dot
that's flying through space surrounded
by other little darts with very
similarly spaced distances yeah Himanshu
yeah so Mike if we see uniformity in
that form in terms of like the distance
between cows like so many galaxies is so
it's so similar they might vary slightly
and that slightly might be hundreds of
millions of light years right but but
but there's so much uniformity why would
we not assume that that uniformity
exists pretty much everywhere and that
all these things that you're seeing that
are so similar you do see binary star
systems you do see single star systems
like sorry but there's also some some
speculation that earth and that our
solar system was one time was a binary
star system right I mean that's one of
the the speculations about that that
object that they find outside the Kuiper
belt that the thing is ten times larger
than Earth they think it might have been
at one point in time a star but this
this uniformity that you see why
wouldn't we think that that that has
it's same implications biologically that
there's some sort of a biological
uniformity and that this happens given
the right sets of circumstances yeah you
should be you should tell them some of
the stuff that you've read that you
don't know is true I mean if the the
stuff was true about the propulsion
stuff I mean anyway he well what have
you read what what you saw
- um you know what are you talking about
spill the beans Bob I got to poke the
bear here get some more liquor in yeah
the well I mean the again the the only
thing I could verify was what I had my
hands on they were you know there was
talk of weapon systems that there were
different projects project Galileo
project sidekick was supposed to be
weapon applications of the craft project
Looking Glass had to do with time any
effects of time in the craft now I don't
think we're not talking about making a
time machine like in science
but we're talking about you know small
distortions intentional distortions of
time and how that can be used you know
as a not as a well it was part of a
weapon Pro how are you informed in this
phase again where there's just the small
briefings that I read but again I don't
really like to talk about those because
I don't have any information on him and
it was just you know small briefings he
told commander flavor that what he saw
might have been a time dilation and not
because gravity affects time you know
space time I'm sure you've heard of that
and you know what
what commander Faber saw as he was in
the f-18 approaching it he said it he
described it as a ping-pong ball in a
cup and shaking it back and forth it was
moving that fast now obviously if
there's anything inside there it's gonna
be battered to hell but you know my
point was was that well one of two
things either there's a gravitational
envelope in there which negates any
inertia effects or you are seeing
through a gravity distortion field so
you know just like you're looking at a a
hot Highway and you see you know an
optical distortion going through there
well the same thing happens in gravity
and the craft may not actually be moving
like that it may just look like it
because you're seeing you can only see
it through the field so it may be making
much more gentle moves I'm not saying
that's it but it has to be one of the
two and the thing shows up 60 miles away
they noticed it on radar 60 seconds
after left commander flavor but it was
at his cap point which is the next point
he was destined to go 260 miles away and
in 60 seconds on radar the same object
ends up there so it's going a mile a
second no they I think the radar just
picked it up in 60 seconds yeah it could
have been there instantly but yeah we
don't know the psychics time nobody
knows that's whole thing also its cycles
like radar cycles min doesn't sweep a
planar array so it just you know
scans around it it random place the
spy-1 does the really cool present do
the whole loop anymore right the point
uh the point is though that the craft
moved to his next location before he
knew where his next location was going
to be Jesus and that I mean that's well
documented so that that's a pretty
shocking piece of information what's
fascinating to me too is that you were
discussing this the the way this reactor
worked and that these things were not
really connected no nothing is connected
there's no wiring at all that freaks me
the [ __ ] out charge your iPhone you know
yeah
yeah yeah I mean that's the that's yeah
I know again but that's just simple
electromagnetic induction revenue Tesla
the scientist had this concept of right
yeah yeah that's what I'm talking mean
Franklin on the worse and he wanted to
send wireless electricity through the
sky and Westinghouse was like get the
[ __ ] out of here with that like when
anybody could just pull electricity yeah
this cab meter yeah they couldn't we
just talk in the car right over trying
to chill them out you know we're talking
about Tesla you know you couldn't be
meter didn't how it all that down so
that's funny bring it up yeah that don't
mean who knows what would have happened
in terms of innovation
had he been allowed to go forward with
that well we probably wouldn't have
computers you think yeah I'm pretty
positive well I mean forget about micro
electronics well this is dumping huge
amounts of electromagnetic energy in the
air and yeah we'd be able to wirelessly
turn on our lights but there'd be no
radio communication the interference
would be something we could would be
overwhelming it would induce electric
currents and anything with a small wire
on it so integrated circuits transistors
would be disintegrated before they were
even you know tested for operation so it
would it ways elect us up yeah it would
have stopped us dead we'd have it'd be
great you can turn lighters on and
heaters from all over the place with no
wires but it would stop modern
electronics and this we became dependent
on it
it would almost be like our dependence
on fossil fuels although its destructive
it's very difficult for us to get off
the nipple it would have changed the
course of how he developed which is so
interesting when you talk about it a
civilization of the star system didn't
even start with fossil fuels they had
115 naturally on their planet and
they're like cool anti-gravity is pretty
awesome
well the fact that they I think it's
important that that actually happened
yeah it might have been stopped in its
tracks for a reason whoa and it's just
it's I think it's incredibly difficult
for us to imagine technological
progression under another timeline other
than one that we've experienced yeah
that's difficult if we imagine what this
alien race must have been like and uh I
mean God just just to be able to see
something to like I mean obviously we've
seen it in different life forms right
like we see the life of certain beetles
in comparison to the life of certain
fish very very different existence very
different life cycles octopus yeah
octopus I mean we see all these
different variables in terms of
biological entities on earth but we
don't see it in terms of technological
innovation as we're the only one that's
intelligent that can innovate we we have
intelligent creatures but they're in the
ocean the only other thing that are like
us are dolphins and orcas and whales and
they don't have the ability to
manipulate their environment and
subsequently because they don't have the
ability to emit and manipulate their
environment we put them in fish tanks
and we're like get in the tank do some
tricks right you know the only thing he
saw in the craft if we were considering
Bob's story the only thing that you he
saw in the craft that he related to it
looked like a human could make was this
honeycomb hatch and I always loved that
because you're like obsessed with this
thing that you could recognize a focus
on that because it was the one thing
that I understood how it worked what was
it and it was it was the access to the
level below and it was well you know if
you take yep a six-pack of beer and you
take out the cardboard dividers mm-hmm
set it on the table you can put a lot of
pressure on the top but if you push it
from the sides it collapses flat mmm so
it was something like that in a
honeycomb shape
that was essentially some sort of sheet
metal and you could walk on that an
upper layer but if you took the corner
stuck your finger in and pushed it
collapsed and made a an entryway hmm so
I thought that was a really unique I had
never seen that before and it was the
only thing in the crap that made
absolute sense to me as it ah we can
make that and all that is as a hatchway
was there any discussion about the
materials that were used to make the
craft I'm sure there was but that was a
metallurgy division had nothing to do
with us she never got a not even the
slightest briefing I don't even know if
it was metal or it was ceramic it's I
think it there's a fine line between the
two now one of the things that's
happened to you that has allowed people
to discredit you was there's obviously
been some sort of an effort to erase
your past yeah some sort of an effort to
erase your education history your
employment history at los alamos in fact
the only way your employment history was
proven at los alamos if someone got a
list a directory of the employees from
the past and read into it and you were
on that list so it proved that you
worked there even though people were
trying to deny and they were trying to
use that as a way to discredit you never
did work at los alamos you weren't real
scientists what was what was that like
to experience I mean of course we're
talking about the 1980's the 1990s when
you could get away with something like
that yeah I always say there are a lot
less a lot less records on computers at
that time it was still file cabinets and
folders but yeah that was frightening
that was one of the first things I think
it's I think George Knapp was the first
one that uncovered that I mean he saw my
birth certificate disappear he
disappeared
yeah there was no record of you being
there was there was no record of that
there was money his mom tells me about
that like it was frightening for her for
he's got a real family you know he's
real person is frightening for her but
if the Los Alamos thing really surprised
me and that there was so adamant that
now this guy never worked here don't be
ridiculous and George went back and
forth you know for I got the letters on
the world yeah
once I mean it was ridiculous but
fortunately somebody came up with a 1982
phone book directory I mean and also
originally I told you you know when I
worked there I was on the front page of
the paper so they were still able to
archive you know break bring that back
from the archives and you know Bob Lazar
a physicist working here at Los Alamos
oh there was at least something there
but somehow George came up with the
phone directory and then George then Bob
took George with cameras into Los Alamos
oh yeah yeah so we flew out there and I
said look come on in I'll show you where
I worked we'll go in well meet people
and George went with me and you know no
gate the place oh yeah you know met
people and you know and Los Alamos was
also the place where they had the
machine that was able to read the the
size of your digits no no that was
awesome that was s4 that was s4 and
explain that so now this was back in the
80s and this is back in the 80s where
when you discuss this people like this
doesn't even exist yeah okay what was it
it was a way you know this is before
fingerprint scanners and you know and
anything of anything a high-resolution
scanner at that time so what it was was
a device that had a little picture of a
hand on a glass plate with pins in it so
you could Jam your hand in there and
there was a bright light above it and a
sensor underneath and when you put your
hand in there the light would turn on
and it would measure the bones in your
finger because the light shone through
your bones and apparently the length of
the bones and your fingers are extremely
unique and easy to measure and they use
that when you put your hands on there
the light would turn on and your badge
would pop out there's it oh there it is
that's that's it and I tried to describe
this to people and they said that is the
most ridiculous thing we've ever heard
and I said hey that my badge came out of
that thing I put my hand on it badge
popped out and that's how I could open
the doors and get into s4 and you know
and everybody discredited that they said
it was [ __ ] it was thought of
science fiction and Jeremy you found
that
I found it through a good friend of mine
named Tyler rogue away and he had some
good sources inside of area 52 where
they also used these for the stealth
program right around that time so now
I've got all these people that worked
within who you know said only if you're
in certain programs would we use this
technology it's kind of [ __ ] actually
they didn't keep it for very long
beginning of biometrics so I was able to
reveal it in my film I kept my mouth
shut until I showed it to Bob you know
the movie is the first time he saw it
was how you see in the documentary
that's his genuine reaction getting
goosebumps that was a great idea the way
you did it thank you man because you
know what guess what I'm actually trying
to see if he's telling the truth that's
how I started you know that I started so
it was really cool to see that that you
get to see it his no actual reaction has
that been verified by other people yeah
so yes so to me it has personally I get
emails every day and people are telling
me where these are used and how they're
used and the send me photos I got a lot
of photos by Danny Matteson and how they
were used right they're not how they
were you invite using yeah but I don't
the most recent one was way more recent
than I thought in another country but
yeah that technology was used so what's
so funny is that this technology even in
the area of 52 where they'd use them for
Tonopah one of the guys who will go on
camera when he will do an interview with
me he was a technician for one of these
and and he hated them cuz they were
really bad they always broke down and
never and he was a technician for him
and he won't tell me where if he worked
at area 52 so is probably Tonopah it's
very separated even on base but yeah so
there was that yeah there is your
education record that was also like what
happened with that that well that
disappeared also you know that I I have
I've never gone I've never gone anywhere
for education I've never gone I never
attended any classes at Cal Tech I never
attended anything at MIT you did attend
classes in those places I did attend
classes in those places do you know
anybody that you went to school with yes
I do and have they verified that they
went to school with you well I give
Jeremy some names but people yeah I the
reason I don't say these names publicly
is
every single time I mentioned a name
somebody gets and you don't want to be
yours yeah yeah of course but what what
is that experience like seeing your
birth certificate erased seeing your
employment is frightening it's it's
absolutely fright it's also the fuel
that the debunkers use the so called air
quotes skeptics I don't like the term
skeptics I want to say this probably
because I really only said this
privately I think it's a sloppy lazy way
to look at things to just be a skeptic
let's be objective and I think there's a
lot of things you should be skeptical of
I think you should you should look at
things and look at things from a
hard-line science perspective but the
idea of skeptics the problem with that
is you're always looking for things to
be [ __ ] yeah and I think that's
dangerous because I think some things
aren't [ __ ] it's confirmation bias
on the other end you did is I need to
take a square thing and put it in a
round hole no matter what and I find a
lot of them to be lazy a lot of them to
be lazy thinkers sure because they're
always putting it into that box instead
of going hmm
instead of just separating their ego
they're trying they're playing a game
and the game is calling [ __ ] I want
to call [ __ ] and I'm gonna line up
all these reasons why it's [ __ ] and
I'm gonna ignore anything that might be
contrary to that definition yeah that
does every time I'm thinking I'm gonna
catch him in something you know all
along this process um I found dr.
Crangle he came forward and said I was
in security briefings with Bob Lazar the
physicist at Los Alamos he went on the
record with me now the other people I
talked with well I won't they go on the
record with me because they're still
working there so that that's the
difference right what is that what can
the public have well or even if they're
not working there that you know they
want to live their lives I mean
obviously people have seen what's
happened to you Mike Thigpen after 30
years yeah really
if you look at all the information on
you know concerning my accounts that's
that's verifiable it can't possibly be a
[ __ ] story anymore it's really way
past that point yeah I mean that was my
big pen is I mean how is that he was
assistant lino
so Mike Thigpen was the
that did the security clearances to go
to the bait one of the guys that was a
guy that you work with he said he did
right and and George Knapp you know
George didn't believe him George put him
through four polygraph tests right he
tried to see man this is a big risk it
sounds interesting but let's see if he's
telling the truth one of the things was
Bob said there's a guy named Ike Thigpen
he did security clearances for the base
and that's a weird name it's a very
specific for 30 years George found this
guy in this weird department that he
didn't even know it was my dig pin the
guy wouldn't talk to me ghosts and I'm
totally goes in for 30 years used
Facebook and Google image match through
his children I was able to find him
after 30 years and I talked him three
times on the phone he lives on the East
Coast he almost went on camera with me
confirmed that he did security
clearances for the base in 1989
confirmed he remembers Bob Lazar and
what you don't know is there's a
handwritten note that a friend of yours
has from Mike what I'd um I'll give it
to you later I don't but that is real
that is actual so handwritten oh this is
what you know this isn't it so when the
I when you're when they do security
Clanton clearances they go through all
your friends and yeah yeah so this is to
Bob and I had people come to me for a
friend of mine that's serving and they
were doing a security clearance for him
and even though I'm like the UFO guy
they did you know the FBI come and visit
my house and make sure that they talk
about my friend and they lift a little
card and when my wife told me to get
away because he didn't know who they
were they left a little card it's super
cute now back then it was a handwritten
note and his friend has it for him that
you haven't seen and oh my god two
decades so if you're listening what is
this card it's just a little handwritten
note with Mike Thigpen signature card
like a like a like a postcard like a
piece of paper that he left on the door
saying when Bob gets back or whatever it
says on it so it's just another little
funny thing I found the guy he does the
security clearances he admitted to me he
did it and he admitted to me he was
dodging George Knapp because when George
said his name on the written on the on
the news
he dropped his fork into his steak into
his potatoes or whatever and he's
looking at his wife he was in trouble
his name's never supposed to be out
they're like there's just a security
clearance guy but you don't want
national attention associated with
anything bob has to say but anyway this
unique name Bob said for 30 years and
the guy goes to George Knapp George
could prove he existed he actually
talked to me man he talked to me three
times he almost went on camera with me
it's just crazy what what do you what
happens after 30 years you just get more
info well that's one of the reasons why
when you and me and Jeremy and George
Knapp had that conversation on the phone
yeah I said I think what we can do with
this podcast is important I really do I
think it's important for people to hear
this from you in a very clear just very
concise way and if you examine all the
information that you've said today if
you you look at all the things that the
detractors have said if you look at all
of the new recent evidence that's coming
out and all these really high-level
people in the military and the
government that are discussing this it
gives you far more credibility then you
would have had in the nineteen when this
came out look yes you can't ignore his
don't worry just because you don't like
it anymore that's why I thought it was
important that you come out and refresh
the world's memory and let people know
and like I said I've been and I say I'm
a fan of yours but I guess I'm a fan of
yours as a human being of a fan of yours
but I've been following you for decades
I've been following the story for
decades I mean I'm kidding I have V
Chester Bob like a lot of the world has
yeah it's crazy well anybody that has
any sort of a vested interest or just a
even a just a fascination with UFOs has
followed your story because there's no
one else there's no one else that comes
for this some guy have said I worked
underground with the aliens they shot my
hand off like this a bunch of wacky
dudes underground there's bases they're
shooting lasers through the Earth's
crust and the movement at light speed
there's a lot of those guys they seem
schizophrenic they seem crazy they might
even be disinformation agents they might
be people that are designed to muddy the
waters which force
or has happened Esau was coming forward
there now it's amazing and by doing this
what you're doing you're providing an
opportunity just for Bob to tell his
story you know believe it or not he can
tell his story it's amazing because more
people will come forward now that are
involved with these projects they'll
come forward with you to me they're
coming forward and so what you've done
here is provide that opportunity if they
need it and it's amazing I just want to
say Bob just don't come forward no don't
come forward - Bob why why were you
freaking nauseous at the beginning of
this like so upset why was your why'd
you have a migraine because that started
off so hard my god us in here like did
this why are you asking him why because
obvious anxiety the guy's gone to 30
[ __ ] years of being persecuted his
birth certificate I want to hear him say
I want them by you guys to say that you
did it I stepped out settle down yeah
well I get it your is hard for you to
get him here you know us yeah well what
really annoys me are the people that
sing you know you guys just came up with
the story to make a bunch of money or
get a bunch of you know attention and
that's a good point so please explain
that any money out of this at all and
I'm a I didn't even let you guys buy
plane tickets for me to come out here or
anything I mean any time like when
Jeremy pre previewed I guess the movie
up in Michigan I mean they it brought in
like a couple thousand dollars I made
sure that two thousand dollars went to
science programs at the local high
schools their dirty money I don't want
to touch it I don't take any money from
this stuff and as far as attention I
hate [ __ ] attention I don't like
being on shows I just want to kind of
hide in the corner and do my own thing
so that's I got enough hugs when I was a
kid okay I don't need any attention so
now the if if you if you think somehow
we came up with this thing then you got
to tell me why we did it well you've
done a great job of making sure you have
your bases covered in that regard that
you haven't profited off of this and
like you said that you have donated
whatever money that came your way to
science programs it's I mean it it
doesn't make any sense
any other way I mean what your but I've
got gotten out of here is what I thought
I was going to get out of here when I
watched a documentary that you what
you're saying makes sense it doesn't
make sense that it's [ __ ] that
happened exactly like I said it did Joe
I believe you in closing is there
anything else you'd like to say no I
can't think of anything other than
really don't come and try to visit me
well I know that you have paid a huge
personal cost to get this information
out and I mean maybe you didn't
understand what that cost would have
been when you first initially came
forward with the story but over the past
thirty years it's been immense it's been
great and I just wanna thank you for
that and thank you for all these people
that would not have gotten this
information and would not have really
had this story any other way no thanks
Jim thank you and thank you Jeremy and
one more time the documentary is
available on Netflix right now
yeah it's called bob lazar area 51 and
flying saucers alright that's it folks
good night
[Music]
[Applause]